With the two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation of the site so we'll start off with
the accuracy first so your accuracy is actually scored from a four so from the number four
you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one any mistakes
that you make whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake
you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two so with a
minor mistake it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a out of block if it's not your
shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor
mistake so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an out of block in the
pattern but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead so that would be a major
mistake so with a minor mistake let's say pattern one for example there's about 20 steps it's not
uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry the 20 steps so the reason for
that one being it needs to be absolutely perfect to get to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not
uncommon let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 30 steps and you made 20 steps and you
made 15 mistakes so what would that be so we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come back
and we'll just calculate the score at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the
left when you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try to
avoid any of these major mistakes so after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the
presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six
six is actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one
for a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression
of energy is also scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed
so with this one whether it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you
are that you do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well
so it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and
fast to get uh high in that in that category so the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm
uh when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just
really fast all the way through it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind
of aspect to it as well so you do need to kind of uh work on your rhythm and that's also scored out
uh the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically
uh how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so uh say you're
doing your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but
you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell though you're not
really confident you're a little bit nervous so that's what i'm going to kind of improve on as
well so let's come around to this side so with this one for color belts and black belts it's
actually scored a little bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your
average so where where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your
average so say you did uh you did all right you did average compared to everyone else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so
if you're less than average in the judge's eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed
you might get a one or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4
so each individual uh category you need to obviously get as high as you can if you're
a black belt generally depending on the competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so
1.3 would be your average uh that you start from so say your parents
speed uh was above average uh average you might get scored a one point say let's say 1.4 for now
say your rhythm was only about average uh it wasn't amazing it might be just a 1.3
but let's say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3
it might drop to say let's say 1.0 so with this one we'll come over
down to this side so with this one uh as i was saying it's a total of uh
10. so that's it for presentation we had 1.7
one two three so you had a 3.7 and so you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously
don't be too discouraged if you do get uh pretty high in your mistakes uh this is with the judges we
have three judges usually at the panel and each judge obviously it's very subjective so
uh from their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may
i may have made a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three judges
and we average it out as well okay so uh say we did our uh 15 mistakes very small mistakes
so if they're all uh minus 0.1 you'd be 1.5 so you go full
point zero minus uh 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would be your accuracy score
so with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a 3.7 here so we add these numbers at
the uh after the judges are finished scoring so you would get for this pattern a 6.2
which is actually very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here
so if you're a color belt uh if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns it's not uncommon
generally for a color belt uh the average is about a four to five so if you get a number between
uh four and five out of ten for your pattern that's actually uh generally considered pretty
good so anything above that uh you can consider yourself pretty good uh if you're a black belt the
average would say because um we're talking here about the the higher presentation as an average
anything from five to two sorry five to six is actually considered uh pretty pretty good and
anything over a seven is actually considered almost world class so if you get a seven for any
of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job so we just went
over here and i'm going to show you a little bit more of a story so just remember accuracy is a 4.0
presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get
two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was
uh i was judge number one i would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side
maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than i did so maybe this one would be a 6.2
be a little bit lower it might be a five point something another judge on the other side they
scored a little bit higher so we'd get three numbers and then we'd average that as well
so i hope this uh helped you guys so make sure you enjoy your competitions and anytime
okay we're gonna practice reading yourself yeah yeah
so um this is minor errors we just click on while you're watching very quickly
yeah and then major errors and then after your poomsae you can score your power and speed
coordination of of rhythm and tempo and expression of energy
yeah and then you can will automatically
compute your scores at the end so we're gonna
we cannot pause this one okay
so
Thank you.